what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
getting ready to go into work here in a
minute but before I did we're
approaching 100,000 subscribers and and
it is unbelievable this is an incredible
experience you know knowing that we're
going to break 100 k is is amazing I
mean it's just it is one of the coolest
things that I ever could have thought of
with this channel um you know it's it's
I do want to say thank you to you guys
want to thank you guys so much for all
the successes have it on this channel so
far you know for all the things that
we've been able to do on this channel so
far i mean it's it's it's unbelievable
you know when when I sit down and I
think that you know less than a year ago
I made a video about jason wyngarde and
now here we are at 100k it is it's
really heartwarming you know it's a
really awesome thing so again I want to
say thank you to you guys um you know
the other thing I want to talk to you
guys about here is is it's getting
current you know with a lot of the
videos and stuff um you know along the
way to 100,000 subscribers you learn a
lot of stuff you learn all different
kinds of things and one of the things
you learn is that everybody everybody
wants something different that everybody
has their favorite thing and everybody
wants to see their favorite thing and
along the way I've learned so much stuff
from so many different people I can't
even begin to tell you guys how helpful
biddings been and just teaching me how
YouTube works you know Cameron was
instrumental in my initial success on
YouTube and but this day is a major part
of helping me grow my youtube channel
you know it's it's a it's crazy you know
with all the help that I've gained so
far and so with green getting current on
on our YouTube channel here's what we're
going to do we're going to take like age
of apocalypse the infinity war stuff
like that we're going to have those as
like background videos or videos are
going to get uploaded maybe once or
twice a week or something like that
maybe even every couple of weeks or so
what we're going to do is we're gonna
start focusing on on current storylines
so we're going to focus on the death of
Wolverine we're going to focus on the
House of M we're going to focus on
Avengers disassembled the death of a
friend is going to be the next thing we
do is for parts it's relatively small
but because this is December I'm
actually going to be moving at the end
of the
month and so we're going to focus on a
lot of these smaller story arcs coming
up we're going to focus on the death of
Wolverine and we're going to focus on
Avengers disassembled and get those
videos sorted out and yeah so um so
again I want to say thank you to you
guys I want to say I appreciate
everything you guys have done to help me
grow so far and here's to another
hundred thousand subscribers I'll catch
you guys later peace